the problem is that Hamas doesn't care
about Israeli children or Palestinian
children and now this one I never
thought I never thought I was going to
say this on this show never God you work
in the mysterious ways you truly do
here's Anna Navaro actually making sense
okay anybody else look
um as a child I live through a Civil War
in nicara nowhere near the violence and
the level of arms that we're seeing uh
right now but I know what it's like to
be uh a child caught in the crossfire
and the violence and the death created
by adults the way I feel about this is
it's heartbreaking and if you are human
you've got to be just as sad to see
innocent children whether they are
Palestinian or whether they are Israeli
the problem is that Hamas doesn't care
about Israeli children or Palestinian
children what they care about is only
one thing wiping Israel off the face of
the earth that is their sole purpose of
existence and I I was reminded of a of a
quote that I'm going to paraphrase from
gold Mayer a premier of uh in a prime
minister in Israel in the past and she
said if Hamas if Palestinians put down
their weapons today there would be no
more violence if the Jews put down their
weapons today there would be no more
Israel and that is the problem that is
problem that for Israel this is about
existence man crazy times make strange
bedfellows right so these are these are
lefties who I don't know that anyone in
this space has been more critical of
these women related to everything and I
think that their their confusion around
leftism and what has been happening in
America and the culture words has led to
a lot of this it really has but finally
finally and and this is I don't know
it's a mystery of life I suppose that's
something so insane so brazenly shocking
so unbelievably horrible could happen
and then boom the gates are open and now
once the gates are open the truth will
set you free so I I actually think that
that this could really shift the way
just Joy thinks fundamentally and and
sunny uh not Sunny we'll get to sunny in
a second because she's gone completely
the other way but Anna Navaro and maybe
Alysa far etc
etc